[Applause]
friendly Martha how are you D why do you
always look so hot I tell you this every
time it's like this last year since I've
last seen you I think it was the The
Sports Illustrated cover came out I
mean that the New York Times did you see
today New York Times um announced their
71 most stylish people of the Year and
that was one of
them
how does it like feel to be again and I
always ask you this how does it feel to
be this hot I I I had to wait a long
time it's like it's like sad you know
you wait so many years and finally
you're hot oh God I was hot when I was
you know
19 I mean is it true that this book will
be number 100 yes I mean how
my H and it's
a it's a simple subject but it's so much
fun to write because what I'm writing
about are my experiences leading up to
the adoption of a a certain recipe uh
there are 100 favorite recipes not my my
not my only 100 favorite recipes 100 of
my favorite recipes and it was so much
fun to put the list together so much fun
to photograph it we it's they're
beautiful photographs it's it's it's
like um it's like a different uh a
different book is it true that you
launched Martha short living the
magazine Empire and all that went with
it at 49 yep cuz I'm going to be 49 in
February so look you have the
future there's the first cover if they
referred to you as a Late Bloomer
Building so much of your Empire at that
age and then you know up until this
moment the Late Bloomer stuff was more
about the money aspects of my life that
was that a term that felt fitting or
like what late bler I love that I'm I'm
a gardener and to be a late bloomer at
49 or 50 oh my gosh it was so great I
felt so great I'd rather be a late
bloomer than a never
Bloomer
right yes and I that's what that that's
what that Sports Illustrated cover
showed too you know what would you call
that oh that's a Late Late
Bloomer that's a hot Bloomer you're so
hot it's true I always say that to you
and I I know you think I'm totally sugy
and yet you put up with me which makes
me so happy she's she's the daughter I
never had the suy daughter it's
[Applause]
[Music]
true